la pierre découverte de dinosaures un
paléontologue à ruiner sa carrière en
1869 Édouard dunger Cup décrit un
nouveau fossile de reptile marin 10
mètres de long une longue queue fine et
plate idéale pour se mouvoir dans l'eau
on l'appellera et l'atmosaurus platyrus
premier et unique fossile de l'espèce de
la même famille que les plésiosaures
avec cette découverte il pensait
ridiculiser son rival haute-miel
charmarche à qui il avait déclaré la
guerre des eaux et ben pas du tout
marche va faire remarquer au monde
entier qui doit avaient inversé le coup
et la queue c'est plus un diplôme de CUS
aquatique et quand on y pense c'est
logique un truc de cet high faisait fuir
tous les poissons mais avec une petite
tête au bout d'un coup fin et allongé il
pouvait se faufiler discrètement stylé
dommage que ça soit